hey everybody driving home from work
i wanted to post a quick video to say
that i
deactivated my twitter account today
alec baldwin has
left twitter the actor and dad of seven
made the announcement in a lengthy video
posted to instagram wednesday night
the uh difficulty the unpleasantness
the uh the harshness the
the bitter and just we just fill in any
word you can't say
anything dark enough to describe a lot
of the crowd on twitter
the 30 rock star admits he made the
decision to leave the platform after he
received
backlash to a joke he recently made
about jillian anderson
which baldwin said was supposed to be
ironic
of course you can't do any irony on
twitter you can't do any irony in the
united states anymore the united states
is
such a uptight
stressed out place and such a unpleasant
place right now
baldwin joked on twitter about anderson
using her american accent during the
golden globes on sunday
when she took home the award for her
performance in the crown
which confused a lot of people on
twitter who thought she was british and
had an english accent
at the time baldwin tweeted quote
switching accents
that sounds fascinating yeah so that
seemed to be a reference to the
controversy surrounding his wife
ellaria and questions regarding her
accent
and cultural heritage and while baldwin
never mentions anderson by name in his
video
he insists he meant no harm the person i
was referring to is somebody i am a huge
fan of huge
huge man and that comment was meant
to just illustrate the point that i find
as i said that the multicultural
expressions of anyone
that's your business sending a message
out
to the actress that was the subject of
my
uh uh my uh comment that i
was not meant at all to be offensive
as for his decision to say bye to
twitter he said it was all just
too negative for him the problem with
twitter is there's a
twitter is a lot of haters twitter is a
lot of haters twitter is you know
one-third
um interesting posts photography things
like that
it's one-third tedious
you know uninteresting prairie
nonsense and then it's one third or more
maybe like a
just abject hatred and malice
and unpleasantness toward the end of his
video the 62 year old actor switched
gears and
opened up about recently welcoming his
baby girl lucia
and being an older dad to the six kids
he shares with his wife
the work is less important to me i don't
really need to work too hard right now
i worked a lot and i try to balance that
you know a lot
my wife and my kids the most rewarding
thing i've ever done i love
my children i know this sounds corny i
love my children
more than i could possibly put into
words i love my wife
more than i could possibly put into
[Music]
words